Our world lead
In a new
report claims
that Russia
has been holding
thousands of Ukrainian children
and a network of so-called
reeducation camps
since the invasion of Ukraine be
almost one year ago.
This report from Yale University
in the US State Department detai
Moscow's efforts to relocate
and reeducate the children
and in some cases forcibly adopt
out or militarily train some of
Moves that the researchers
claim are clear war crimes.
CNN's David
McKenzie follows
one mother's journey
to reunite with her daughter,
who was stuck
in one of these hideous camps
weeks ago.
We first met Tatyana,
like her
in Kiev in a shelter
for displaced families.
All of the mothers here are sepa
from their children by the traum
in more trees.
Emotions overwhelmed me when Lil
When I realized what was happeni
it terrified me
all I wanted for the best for my
At the time
who 11 year old
daughter
Lillia stuck in a Russian camp
in occupied Crimea.
All the lessons are in Russian.
At first glance,
the retreat seemed
like any other summer camp,
but the loyalty expected
from Ukrainian children is cryst
Part of what
a new Yale University
study calls systematic education
But Tatiana and Lily, a story be
A year ago,
the home
hometown of Kherson fell quickly
to advancing Russian troops.
Within days,
the occupiers began
a campaign to ratify the populat
often coercing
thousands of parents like Tatian
to send their kids to the camps.
But when Ukrainian forces took b
her son in November,
Tatiana's daughter
was on the wrong side of the fro
We provide
rescue mission for children
who were abducted
and now in Russian Federation
and in Crimea.
Mikala Kleber,
the founder of Save Ukraine,
declined to say
exactly how they negotiated thei
into enemy territory,
just that
their mothers can't do it on the
It's impossible to communicate
with any Russians
because
you can ask these mothers,
they don't want to give children
But Tatiana was ready to take th
I'm worried, of course,
you cannot even imagine
my emotions inside.
It's fear and terror.
It's emotional that I could see
And this is a big deal for me in
11 mothers and one father
putting on a brave face.
But theirs is a perilous route
from Ukraine by road to Poland
and to Russian ally Belarus
through the Russian Federation
to occupied Crimea.
My daughter, who
we were counting
every kilometer on approach,
I could feel it with every cell
in my body.
I was very emotional
when we were closer and closer.
Save Ukraine spent many months p
this moment
reuniting families shattered by
returning children
who just wanted to go home to Uk
Once the answer to meet
it was an outburst of emotions.
Once we embraced,
it was like a great weight
lifted In the end,
they gave up the children willin
But Save
Ukraine says that hundreds,
perhaps thousands, remain.
Our two countries are at war,
says Tatiana.
But they are good people everywh
You know, Jake, when
the mothers were offered
for their children
to go to these camps,
many of them were very
conflicted about it
because it got their children
away from the frontline, from da
in many cases.
But because of this war
and the fluid
nature of the front lines at tha
many are now separated from them
and having to go on this
really desperate journey
through multiple countries
to get their children back.
Those camps insist that the pare
to pick them up.
You can kind of understand that
the Russians are calling this
a State Department, a Yale study
They say they are just trying to
children safe.
But there's clear evidence
that there is indoctrination
going on in this camp.
And it's part of the policy
of the Kremlin
to make those parts of Ukraine b
Russian Jake.
All right.
David McKenzie in Kiev, Ukraine,
thank you so much for that movin